I'm here
[music]
kilometer
wh hmm
me I
'm starting out baby [music] me aname
ni
[music]
me
can
[music]
me
ni
wh
[music] I
won't publish it  Hey,
yes, the contract has been concluded
Chise Hatori,
aren't you having
trouble
breathing?
]
They're different from the ones you usually see
Oh
tan
ame
Anything is fine I
just want a place where I can go home
200 Look at me why are you like this I was talking about 25 cups of food that I can't open
20 times Is there anyone who
likes this song
?  Wow
, let's get the reception room ready
The subject is 5 million pounds,
isn't it
?  I didn't think you'd show up in this
auction, but if you don't follow the rules,
you'll be in trouble.  Look,
he's bought a waiting room 4. Go ahead, it's a
monster
. I can hear you.
Be
careful with your
mouth.  The 3D data is
Slei Can
you see it after all Hmmm [music] Is it me?
You seem to have eyes that can clearly see your mind You're
lucky
You can't pick up that kind of luggage But Yuki,
you're good luck  Let's make it so that I can think of it
Huh,
actually, I'm in trouble if I can be
so
lethargic.
I might be dizzy I'm a
shadowy power Give
me
and Eddie
A water bottle of clouds Wrapped in
a branch of flowers
Please, where am I?
How do I get here from inside a building?
It's going to be
outdated, but I
welcome you as my base It's
great, it's okay,
no
attitude
[music]
I'm coming alone
]
I can't go upstairs from my eyes, but I ca
n't get warm unless I reach my shoulders
.  I'll entrust you to someone, but
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah
9 n eh eh ah ah 9 n eh
eh we're a request in human terms  You can't read it in words
Come on, like a neighbor or a good friend
Hey, you should
do it The thorn wizard makes a funny imitation
Madani More than Kinta of the past More valuable than any flower that blooms in the land of fairies  Mitsukubi,
cute, cute Our agriculture and forests, my
love
Eat and calm down
Oh,
it looks like you're really being welcomed. You look like you
want to know a lot of
things.
Is it true that you're a wizard? It's true
[Music
] A
disciple is a disciple.
It was
[music]
What is that sleigh vega?
It doesn't matter if you can see it or not, it doesn't matter if you see it or not, it's a worker bee Maiko Mii, it
seems like you can see my posture, but
that's rare for you guys.
Because actions aren't always good for humans, but being
liked means you can't run out of help
Magic needs their help, so it's a very important question.I'm
sure you can
be a very good wizard
[Music]
That's why I don't feel like doing this or that, but you don't have the
right to veto that, right?
[Music]
Family
This is a cursed stone
It's a natural hole at the bottom of the river
.  Music]
You must be tired,
good night from the lecture, can
you guide her
?  I don't go for a walk around here Iimori is good, so it's
okay I'm a little mad, so I'm going to take a walk inside and I'm a little tired I'm soundly tired
Aura horror
Music] It's
kind of bright Even after we pass, I
can still see this Nechi line family There's
no one I
was taken in by various relatives
You may not have been here,
hey
[music]
Hey,
I've walked a long way
already  I don't
care if I don't have it, so I used the plate of Shotokuthorn to deceive them.
It's supposed to be, so don't
worry Ah, it's just vacant From here onwards is the land of fairies, fun and fun
Our world and yours
Let's go for a
moment
Stand up
No family is waiting for you, right
?
i say what's wrong i have to
go
home there's no reason for you to go back to that house you never asked
me to stay here before he
said it's a
toy  If you get tired of thinking about it, you can throw it away
Even if it's only once, you told me that you're family
[Music]
My
puppy boots It seems you've already learned your true nature  I'm lucky I can lose it I
'm missing it this time
Next is Salamander's great ancestor
Can an oddball protect our Robi?
Many of them are troublesome things that lure you in with sweet words
.  I'm a disciple, so please rely on
me Warm Keto I feel like I'm kind of
stiff What are you doing
? It's easy to get lost in Yonomori.
[Music]
Okumura:
Who didn't say who you were?
[music]
ni 2
house a 4
me
[music]
funny Shall we prepare for the moon A
girl heading to London with a witch A
stranger in a strange town The world gently reaches out to a lonely girl but
yeah
goo